welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber Alec Murdock the
disgraced lawyer convicted of killing
his wife Maggie and Son Paul is starting
a new week in prison and staring down
two life sentences here's a look at
Murdoch's latest mug shot taken after he
was sentenced on Friday now shaving an
inmate's head am I look strained it's
actually protocol it's done there to
prevent lice Murdoch went to a facility
where he's going to be evaluated and
eventually assigned to a maximum
security South Carolina Prison a juror
from Alec Murdoch's trials talking about
the guilty verdict and the evidence that
he saw over six long weeks long crimes
and Jeanette Levy has the story during
the trial James was known only as juror
5 30. now in his first television
interview following the verdict he is
talking about the evidence that stood
out most to him during that six-week
trial I think that it's true that he did
love his family James is a 22 year old
construction manager and is about the
same age as Paul Murdock would be if he
were alive today
James said that all of the evidence was
important but one thing stood out that
kennel video
I think it's a very crucial piece and I
think that it's
incredible timing as to when they were
able to get it and I think it's
incredible timing on Paul apart
I don't think that anyone would have
ever known that he was down there if it
wasn't for that video I think that
there's a lot of evidence that points
towards Alex but I feel like that does
solidify it also important Murdoch's own
words about the deaths of Paul and
Maggie Murdoch on the stand Mr Griffin I
didn't shoot my wife or my son any time
ever I think that part of the way that
he is able to be so good at talking to
people is that he's convincing and I
think that whenever he's convincing he's
convincing himself as well and I think
he's able to do that because he often
meshes the truth with a lie the jurors
initial vote nine guilty three not sure
James said the jurors were able to move
through questions about evidence quickly
because they wrote down questions in the
Jury Room during breaks since they were
not allowed to take notes James's
brother is a Colleton County Sheriff's
deputy who actually responded to Mozelle
the night of the murders James says that
the defense was aware of this fact and
approved of him being on the jury for
Law and crime daily I'm Anjanette Levy
James isn't the only person intimately
involved in the straw to speak to the
media you see one of Murdoch's own
lawyers appeared on news Nation Jim
Griffin worked very closely with Dick
karputley and often cross-examining some
witnesses walking others through
evidence he also delivered the closing
argument for the defense Griffin says
that the defense plans to appeal the
verdict on the grounds that the
financial crimes evidence should never
have been allowed in they maintain it
was way too prejudicial during a segment
on news Nation Chris Cuomo asked Griffin
who they thought was behind the killings
if Murdoch didn't do it
certainly if we had proof of who did it
we would come forward with it so we we
did not have any credible evidence of
of other people who may have committed
these murders and the reason we didn't
have it is because the state really
didn't look me on Alec other than the
individuals that were directly involved
in the boating accident which
which you know frankly Alec told him
that night I don't believe it was the
individuals directly involved in the
boating accident at the time he thought
that it was some deranged person who who
heard or viewed or was in contact with
all this negative chatter about
Paul not getting Justice because he's a
privileged kid and that took it upon
himself whether that ultimately what
occurred or not I mean we just didn't
have the information to go there we
don't have the power of subpoena we
don't have the power of search warrants
we can't subpoena cell phone records and
so we were limited all right I'm joined
by my co-hosts and legal analyst defense
attorney Brian buckmeyer former trial
Attorney Terry Austin Terry several
jurors that speaking out I feel like
there might be a risk right that the
jury revealing all this couldn't that
help Alec Murdock in an appeal
absolutely it could help him and then
feel you know there are different
grounds for appeal you talked about one
of them the financial crimes legal error
getting into the case but during
misconduct is also a large area where
you can have an appeal if they are
forced to make a decision and it wasn't
something they really wanted to do if
they spoke to someone outside the
parameters of that trial and we had
something like that happen here and that
juror was dismissed and you know you can
also have a juror who is you know just
not in a position to make that decision
and and I think if any of these jurors
Who come out and say that they were
forced or in any way shape or form they
looked at evidence outside of the trial
it could be a grounds for appeal well
talking about appeals Brian any other
avenues that the defense May explore
that we haven't thought of yet yeah
Jesse one thing that kind of sticks out
to me that I don't know whether or not I
would win is this writing questions in
between the breaks they're not allowed
to take notes to Terry's point we would
have never known that they were taking
questions down during the break for me
you Terry I even the producers write our
questions here and to write a question
you have to consider the information in
which you're asking the question about
well what's another way of saying
deliberation well a long form of
consideration so how do you write the
questions without considering the facts
and if you're not allowed to consider
the facts until the case is given to you
aren't you not following the judge's
rules right there I mean that could
potentially be a reason for appeal I've
never seen it argued before but it kind
of makes sense well I'll tell you what
so this is still the murder case right
but still ahead on Long crime daily
what's next for convicted killer Alec
Murdoch we're digging into other cases
that Murdoch is connected to and what
will happen now that the disgraced
attorney is behind bars
foreign
our coverage on what's next for Alec
Murdock continues now the disgraced
lawyer may be in prison and likely to
stay there but the murder trial wasn't
the only legal trouble he's facing in
this segment we're going to take a look
at where the financial crimes stand
what's next for the lawsuit connected to
the boat wreck and whether the death of
Gloria Satterfield the Murdoch's
longtime housekeeper is going to be
investigated further so let's Dive Right
In First up Alec Murdock he still faces
99 Financial crimes charges prosecutors
say he stole at least eight million
dollars in settlement money from clients
at his Law Firm the state said that
those charges were Murdoch's motive for
killing his wife and son because he
wanted to distract from his financial
misdeeds in fact when he took the stand
during the criminal trial Murdoch
repeatedly confessed to stealing money
from his clients
I admit candidly in all of these cases
Mr Waters that I took money that was not
mine
and I shouldn't have done it
I hate the fact that I did it
I'm embarrassed by
I'm embarrassed for my son
I'm embashed for my family
and I don't dispute that I did it over
and out of the next legal issue in 2019
two years before being murdered Paul
Murdoch was involved in a boat crash on
a South Carolina River it's believed
that Paul was driving the boat drunk
when it hit a bridge pylon six young
people all under 21 were on the boat at
the time and one woman Mallory Beach did
not resurface after the crash and her
body was found a week later Paul was
indicted on three counts of boating
Under the Influence but was murdered
before the case went to trial Mallory
Beach's mother and family members of
other people on the boots boat sued the
Murdoch's in January of this year a
judge approved a settlement between
Beach's family and two of the Murdoch
family members Mark tensley the man who
represented beech's mother testified
about the case during the Alec Murdoch's
double murder trial
play I recognized that
the case against Alec if he were a
victim of some vigilante would in fact
be over it would be a when you're asking
for a money judgment
people have to be motivated to give you
that money judgment if Alec had been
victimized by vigilante
um
nobody would have brought a verdict back
against Alec and and finally South
Carolina law enforcement investigators
are also looking into the death of
Gloria Satterfield the Murdoch's
longtime housekeeper Satterfield died in
2018 after allegedly tripping over the
family's dogs and falling down the
stairs at Moselle Maggie and Paul were
the only Witnesses sled agents want to
exhumed satterfield's body and see if
they can identify a more conclusive
cause of death an autopsy hadn't been
done at satterfield's funeral her son
Tony says Murdoch approached him about
filing a lawsuit so that insurance would
approve a multi-million dollar payout
eventually after the murder is an
attorney for the satterfields was able
to get some of that money but prior to
that Tony Satterfield says he didn't
know about the payout that had already
been given to Alec Murdoch
did he ever tell you about a 505
thousand dollar settlement that already
had occurred no
did the defendant ever tell you that he
also had a five million dollar umbrella
policy no
did he ever tell you that there had been
a recovery against that no
did he ever tell you that I'm in
recovery for 3.8 million dollars against
that no
did he ever pay you one penny of 3.8
million dollars no
Brian how bad does it look for Alec
Murdock and these other open cases Jesse
it looks very very very bad starting off
with the financial crimes he's already
testified to committing at least some of
these crimes the only question is which
one of the 19 indictment and 99 charges
is he agreeing to and that he's not he's
facing potential centuries in jail for
those combined charges and so I think
it's also the prosecution's motive or
probably it should be their motive to
try to get that charge solidified as
best as possible when it comes to the
financial crimes that taking from the
statofields family or even the 2021
um attempted suicide on his life he's
already committed to those he's already
said that he did them all doesn't matter
how many years in jail are going to tag
on to that in the murders think about
what Brian said centuries in prison
Terry let's go to the Gloria Satterfield
case the death of her um how difficult
is it to investigate cases years after
the fact it's going to be very difficult
here they are exhuming Gloria
satterfield's body and that alone tells
you something there's going to be
decomposition obviously physical
evidence that might have been available
back in 2018 probably not available now
you're going to have witnesses who might
not be available or their memories might
have faded so it's going to be overall
much more difficult for the prosecution
to pursue this case but they have to do
the investigation and if it turns out
there's something that is not straight
they're going to pursue and try to
figure out whether or not there is a
motive for a murder versus an accident
and it could be Maggie and Paul were
Witnesses it could be Alec Murdock
wanted to get money from the insurance
it could be he wanted to cover up
something she might have found all of
these are speculation and things that
people are reporting and why they are
investigating that crime well I think we
can all agree even though he was
convicted the Alec Murdoch story Saga
will continue in a lot of different
realms